très heureux de vous retrouver notre
invité principal ce soir c'est christian
louboutin
[Applaudissements]
et sur le bulletin un bon soir vous êtes
aujourd'hui christian le plus célèbre
créateur de souliers du monde toutes les
stars portent vos fameuses escarpins à
semelles rouges et je crois que l'on
peut dire que si à 30 ans une femme n'a
pas des louboutin elle a raté sa vie
alors juste un petit sondage dans le
public c'est elle qui serait prête à
tuer pour avoir des louboutin lever la
main
toutes les filles ont alors christian
vous connaissez les missions en p1 nous
serons tous les deux nous parlerons de
vous de vos origines votre enfance notre
vocation de notre apprentissage de
carrière et du tri en planétaire de vos
talents hauts et des drames que ça cause
toutes les 30 secondes dans le monde une
cheville ce brise à cause de vous
voilà l'émission s'appelle salut les
terriens
[Musique]
alors question en rebond soir alors la
reine rania de jordanie catherine
deneuve cameron diaz caroline de monaco
nicole kidman angélina jolie renée
zelwegger by and see dita von teese
sofia coppola victoria beckham addona
britney spears et jennifer lopez porte
vos souliers à semelles rouges en
question c'est la gloire mais c'est
surtout la preuve que les femmes ont un
rapport très particulier avec leur
solide c'est ça qui me plaît dans la
chanson et vous êtes devenu une fashion
ikon quand je pense que tout est parti
d'une demande me mathy qui voulait avoir
une taille normale au départ
non en fait tout a commencé le 7 janvier
1964 vous naissez à paris dans un
quartier populaire le 12e arrondissement
votre mère irène vous élève vous et vos
quatre soeurs et votre père roger est
ébéniste pour la sncf famille modeste
d'origine bretonne et vous vous avez un
air métis dans une famille très blanche
vous êtes jamais demandé pourquoi si
bien sûr je me bouge on se pose toujours
des questions sur le facteur mais c'est
en voyant des cousins du côté de mon
père que j'ai arrêté de penser aux
facteurs à un moment vous inventez
impasse et égyptien pour justifier sa
non oui tout à fait comme j'avais l'air
même plus métis que maintenant j'étais
persuadé que j'étais égyptiens alors
vous grandissez dans un monde de femmes
jettent le petit dernier donc les soeurs
parle de tous devant vous ce qui fait
que j'étais vraiment comme au théâtre je
regardais et j'avais des grandes soeurs
qui faisait leur numéro les problèmes
les téléphones fiancés les mensonges et
tout est mais j'étais pas considéré
comme une commune vision masculine et
c'était rigolo et c'est de là que date
votre vénération des femmes absolument
alors à 12 ans vous vous réfugiez
souvent au musée des arts africains et
océaniens qu'à l'époque s'appelait
encore le musée des colonies porte dorée
vous découvrez l'exotisme vous attrapez
votre goût des voyages et là un jour
vous voyez un idéogramme une chaussure à
talon
barré d'une croix rouge qui interdisait
en fait le musée aux talons aiguilles
c'est ce dessin qui m'a fait comprendre
que tout est dessiné que dans le fond on
sait pas forcément quand on est un
enfant mais tout ce qu'on voit tout ce
qui hélas était dessiné la chaise a été
desserrée votre costume le micro le
bureau la frise précise a été dessiné
les lumières ont été faites tout est
dessiné alors se regardant en regardant
ce dessin je me suis dit tiens c'est
drôle on peut même dessiner des souliers
de femmes ouais et donc à la base
c'était plutôt un c'était un hobby
c'était presque un tic va redessiner
toujours ce dessin et c'est ainsi que je
pensais pas du tout que c'était un
métier rock qu'on vous voyez une
prostituée à la foire du trône avec des
talents au vous flashé sur elle et on
prenait un coup de pied dans le cul du
mak koidu souteneur oui je vois
ses souliers ce dessin qui s'était mis à
exister qui était sur les pieds de
quelqu'un mais c'était vraiment comme un
dessin animé pour main j'ai suivi mais
j'ai suivi vraiment les souliers détruit
les talons et un moment on m'a attrapé
de dos et on m'a donné un grand coup de
pied dans les fesses et on m'a dit tu
dégages alors je les fais vous dit si
j'avais vu une signalétique interdisant
les tracteurs je serais devenu
constructeur de matériel agricole
absolument c'était vraiment l'univers du
dessin qui m'intéressait et c'était
aussi quand même le rapport à la danse
et aux femmes mais c'était pas la mode
clairement pas c'était c'était vraiment
ce dessin quoi alors à l'école dont vous
êtes le fou qui décide des souliers de
la journée à sur les cahiers sur les
pupitres exactement il y avait cette
publicité de guy degrenne on voyait un
enfant qui devait avoir qui étaient plus
jeunes qui devais avoir 8 ans et puis le
professeur longueuil en disant ah
monsieur guy degrenne vous serez jamais
rien et on regarde ce cahier de dessin
qui était donc découvert est alors à
cause de cette publicité on me disait
toujours il se prend pour guy degrenne
alors à l'âge de 14 ans vous commencé à
déserter les bancs de l'école pour les
fêtes de la main bleue du palace vous
rencontré votre bande d'amis farida eva
ionesco pieds agiles à saison donc école
de couture l'académie road horreur et
puis vous devenez stagiaires aux folies
bergères et là vous offrez des croquis
au meneuse de revue lisette malidor rita
renoir norma duval vous êtes fasciné par
l'hyper féminité de ces femmes ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'une femme on les
danseuses particulièrement mais une
femme dès qu'elle se met sur les talons
la silhouette se redessine complètement
la silhouette par en avant le centre de
gravité basculer donc le corps cambre
les fesses partent en arrière n'a pas de
la poitrine plonge en avant donc ça fait
un des cinq hommes savaient qu'ils se
disent qu'ils se finit par juste une
petite goutte c'est très joli vous dites
la ligne d'une femme part du duo des
cuisses et va jusqu'à la pointe des
pieds visuellement quand on regarde une
danseuse la ligne de la jambe elle
commence à la hanche et elle descend
jusqu au décolleté ce qu'on appelle le
décolleté du pied c'est à dire la partie
avant où s'arrête le soulier donc qu'une
le décolleté profond la jambe et wana
c'est le secret
alors christian a 18 ans quand même vous
dit qu'il est temps de travail pour de
vrai vous ouvrez le bottin à maison de
couture vous appeler chez balmain la
personne répond vous appeler chez dior
la directrice hélène de mortemart qui
vous propose d'aller apprendre le boulot
en fait chez jours dans un roman qui est
la capitale de la chaussure et de la
gontrie en france ensuite vous dessinez
des chaussures freelance vous vendez vos
dessins à saint laurent à chanel en 1991
vous créez votre société et un an plus
tard anna wintour c'est à dire la
directrice de vogue celle qui a été
croqué dans le diable s'habille en prada
passez la porte de votre boutique et là
c'est lent c'est quoi le flash sur vos
ce qui s'est passé c'est que moi je
n'étais pas du tout au point quand les
acheteurs américains sont arrivés ils
venaient pour acheter l'hiver c'était
l'été
il me dit baye à cet hiver la ccl quoi
je dis c'est l'hiver mais c'est l'année
dernière c'est fini dans un mois 10 mais
on s'en fout personne ne vous connaît
dit oui mais c'est vieux déjà ah mais
non ces vieux pour vous mais c'est
nouveau pour tout nouveau pc alors j'ai
dit bon bah écoutez et ça m'a finalement
faciliter notre première collection et
qu'ils ont fait a été revendu un an
après
la touche finale en fait ce sera les
semelles rouges et une fille à qui je
travaillais qui venait essayer les
souliers alors c'était pas un énorme
boulot parce que quand les souliers t'es
pas essayé elle était là un tout petit
peu à se raser alors comme elle sera
elle se faisait les ongles alors je lui
ai attrapé son vernis à ongles et puis
j'ai coloré la semaine et je me suis dit
je vais faire les semaines de couleurs
au départ je voulais faire différentes
couleurs en fait je pensais faire une
couleur par saison ouais et puis tout de
suite c'est devenu une identité j'ai
fait tout de suite la semelle rouge est
immédiatement des femmes sont revenus
dans le magasin et 10ème et c'est génial
je me suis fais draguer je me rappelle
cette femme qui avait dit mais c'est un
vous savez mais vos souliers c'est les
aspirateurs amis n'est-ce pas
et en fait c'était c'est vrai que c'est
comme un dialogue ce qu'on se retourne
sur une femme et c'est un signal à feu
vert rouge voilà
ça vaut combien une paire de louboutin
ça commence à
450 euros et puis ça peut aller à
suivant les matières ça peut aller à
très très cher c'est à dire que je crois
qu'une paire de bottes en crocodile ce
qui doit être à peu près ce qui est plus
cher doit coûter 15 mille euros en
dessous
aujourd'hui christian vous avez des
points de vente dans le monde entier une
usine en italie une maison à louxor un
voilier sur le nil et les barbies
louboutin et des barbies l'aube ou tard
maintenant alors latex et twelve bien
gelé
donc en fait vous allez continuer à
dessiner des chaussures là mais oui je
continue au dessous de votre vie vous
aurez fait ce à quoi toute ma vie durant
pour l'instant oui absolument vous avez
dessiné combien de modèles pour le
moment chaque collection je commence
avec
506 en croquis qui descendent à 300
prototype et ça arrive à 150 mais disons
deux cents 200 milles vous avez fait
deux cent mille croquis de chaussures
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux